er steht ganz feld plays dem aus von
andy rihs morgen dichte guten morgen
lukas geht es ist gerade neu nur acht
ich bin enorm fit tatsächlich für meine
verhältnisse und ich bin einfach ultra
high was im heutigen blog einfach alles
passieren
das ist übrigens laufe hier und lanciert
das hältst du davon dass im heutigen
blog wirklich eine menge geil ich freue
mich auch darauf dass kurze ablaufplan
was in diesem blog alles passieren wird
also jetzt gerade ist donnerstag ich
habe jetzt gleich erstmal noch ein
arzttermin weil ich ein bisschen winter
abgeben muss welche nächste als hätten
paar operationen unsere habe auf jeden
fall fällig danach der heute abend nach
köln und morgen werde ich mir mit marx
einen lederhose kaufen gehen wir werden
noch viele andere sachen machen aber
jetzt würde ich sagen ist mir die zähne
[Musik]
und ich finde ganz ehrlich müdigkeit ist
ein bisschen wie wenn man betrunken ist
das sind so die theorien von luca ich
weiß nicht ob irgendeiner form an mich
oder so getroffen hatte aber wenn man
halt so ein bisschen angetrunken jetzt
sind zu bewegungen der mann wie so guckt
ein bisschen verlangsamt und genau das
gleiche stelle ich gerade meinen körper
fest weil ich halt einfach ein bisschen
übel
also bin ich gerade betrunken ich habe
vor allem wieder so ultrabook auf kölner
heute abend wieder dahin morgen sich max
und sowie der stimmen und ich mache auch
morgen eine challenge mit max aber jetzt
gehe ich erst mal zum arzt
wer ist der größte vollidiot der welt
ihr könnt euch ja vielleicht daran
erinnert dass ich heute morgen die zähne
geputzt habe um das was ich gerade beim
arzt machen musste war ein blumen
atemtest und naja zahnpasta durfte ich
da wohl zwölf stunden vorher nicht
benutzen wer hat sie anfasst dann
benutzt ich musste jetzt neuen termin
vereinbaren für nächste woche für mich
ist das überhaupt kein problem ich fahre
diese woche einfach mal hin und alles
gut nur ich muss erstmal einer man
beibringen und sie ist halt immer hart
abgefangen ich will mir zu hause
angekommen und ich weiß nicht ob man da
war hier geht gerade komplett die welt
unter also weil sommerregen möchte wann
tatsächlich eher weniger aus dem auto
steigen und es geschafft durch den regen
warum guckst du so böse naja ich bin
nicht rangekommen weil ich mir leider
heute morgen ist irgendwie ein bisschen
traurig verkauf läuft
[Musik]
du arschloch ich mache mir jetzt auf
jeden fall erstmal sich ich habe gerade
max gesprochen wir werden uns einerseits
morgen treffen um den challenge
aufzunehmen also dem titel gelesen
das werden wir halt nachher in diesem
video gleich machen und andererseits
werden wir uns auch eine lederhose
kaufen die wenig gehetzt die sache auf
oktoberfest war das vollidioten
ich bin noch relativ viele rechnungen
durchgegangen
wäre es auf jeden fall mit meiner mom
noch einmal alle kennen geschenke
durchgehend die ich bekomme aber auf den
letzten fan treffen weil die macht das
mal ganz gern also ich bin ja schon
alles durchgegangen
da gibts noch was du jetzt noch mal
durchgehen volt hast ja wenn ich mal
hier zu hause bin müssen wir all die
ganzen sachen durchgehend so recht und
so weiter und so fort meinem namen
wollte mit mir noch die verein geschenke
durch jemand der selber auch ein paar
sachen bekommen dabei haben wir das hier
wieder gefunden das hat nicht so hallo
handelt die ganzen geschenke aber das
wollen haben mädchen wohl drauf da war
ich zeige es gerade super es ist schon
selbst gemacht das armband was ich bei
dem video der ist bekommen habe wohl
auch gut drauf steht aber ich war als
erstmal zurück nach köln
ich sitze im auto und fahren nach köln
und ich sitze im auto was sich hier
hallo köln nach turbolader habt ihr die
fahrt schöne wäsche us agent war
ich habe alle sachen ausgepackt ich mit
dem bielefeld hatte und wenn ich erst
mal nach draußen
okay das ist kartenform davor aber auf
jeden fall ist es hart am rechner oder
das ist halt deswegen werde ich jetzt
tatsächlich im september meine
winterjacke anziehen so weit kommt doch
hier in deutschland ich habe gehört
einfach bei sport1 gelesen dass durch
einen sturm der kölner fans in london
also ich bin ja gerade europa league
gegen arsenal ist das spiel dadurch
irgendwie erst um 10 uhr angepfiffen
wird also folge nachdem chipkarten
training im winter von dem man in
winterjacken hätte ich auch die macher
ist auch noch ne machst du dich
anzunehmen ich bin zu hause der dusche
ich glaube das nicht so lange nicht mehr
gesehen
ich habe gerade erfahren dass abend das
1 1 gegen den fc geschossen hat die
sache ist ich bin eigentlich kein fan
aber so support your local ist und
international ist man ja immer für die
deutschen mannschaften nein ich sehe
gerade das erste top drei zu eins
gefunden hat gegen köln
[Musik]
ich gehe jetzt aber auf den vorschlag
meine damen und herren das training
gerade mit max hat mich schon hart noch
auseinander genommen deswegen europe /
und zwei minuten ich glaube ich wäre in
diesem blog wiki das größte highlight
ist aber in zwei minuten lounge pelz
neue kollektion und das shirt die caps
sich ganz geil aber sein ob dritte zu
gehen dass die kritik darf und die
heldin in dieser verfassung ist
eigentlich aktuelle sie negative zeit
die seite freunde aber es ist noch nicht
gelöst obwohl es tatsächlich schon 12
uhr ist und mein internet ist ein arzt
habe die kneipe im einkaufswagen bin
aber gerade in line to check out also es
kann sein dass sich noch verpackt
ich habe die kette hier bekommen diese
cap hier habe ich mir geholt die ist
auch schon wieder das soll dort beckens
nicht jeder so wird die auf damen herren
gleich kommen max zettl und schon lange
nicht mehr der präsentation gesehen dann
habe ich ein surfer - heute abend kommen
wahrscheinlich noch jona wahrscheinlich
auch von youtube und auf carola und
pauli das wird noch bei freunden ob
düsseldorf aber jetzt gleich den markt
kommen machen wir das mal eine helium
scheinen
ich warte gerade die ganze zeit darauf
dass max rezept bekommen sind dass wir
quasi endlich diese dumme helium endlich
[Musik]
der kali haben sie bock darauf ist eine
helium sache zu machen
meine damen und herren genähert und der
helium flamme mein gott die große spiele
das ist auf jeden fall jede flasche die
können die bundesbürger heidfeld ist
natürlich ist da ich hoffe nur schwer
andere richtung nicht
es ist packen schwere reden wie die hand
wieder geben die gegen die im
uhrzeigersinn ist doch jährigen die
uhrzeiger okay leute das offenbart immer
[Musik]
jetzt du mich verarschen muss um ihn
[Applaus]
steht ganz beenden und plätzen außer dem
auf und ausbau hingewiesen
nein
wir begrüßen die nation mit helium
[Musik]
du bist ja freundlich dass du mich zum
gesang begleitet mein gott in new york
wohin fahren wir jetzt genau auf die
rheinterrassen seitdem wir hier sitzen
ist das wetter irgendwie immer mehr
zugezogen geworden ist glaubt dass ich
denke dass ich bitte für ein ehrenmann
ich bestimme extra ein mini wieder mit
jona chips und was zu trinken hat es auf
instagram laser luca ist abonnieren
zuschauer dabei und ihr dürft mir nicht
durch die haare schön falls sie mich
irgendwann mal sehen sollte auf jeden
fall schon jetzt nach einer neuesten
cabrio strecke und werden nur noch ein
bisschen
das rein gefahren wurde
bevor die idioten als jetzt haben wir
hier werde es gerade schön
schnitzelessen danke nochmal für die
einladung jeden fall sind da vorne
studien lehrräume und die wird auch
thema im bachelor repliziert wieder
ihrem schönen 911 carrera gts falls sie
gerade durch so köllner tunnel auf dem
weg nach düsseldorf ja ich weiß es nicht
allzu verwunderlich könnte schon das mit
einer meiner besten freundin und dann
sehen wir uns jetzt wieder an
zusammen haben sie schon lust heute köln
feiern zu gehen
entspann sich ein haben hier ganz kurz
bei allen bedanken die lokal süßigkeit
geschenken ich kann sie dann nicht mehr
essen
heute arbeitet abholt hast bist du da
hingekommen ist gefragt ob ich augen
oder münster zu sagen will was also wir
jetzt gerade diese fleck entdeckt und
sogar tipps gegeben wie man den
entfernen kann halo hausmann aber nicht
alle laser ducati jetzt wo es aufnahme
zu machen was aber es war einfach
niemand ist hier sehen wir einen
hässlichen smiley noch hat sich zwar
noch nicht so ganz herzliches marlies
ist sicher computer noch mäßig ist
mileys hässliches wunderschöne oder das
ist die treppenstufen computer hier den
sie luca die kleine rutsche
[Musik]
die erste gratis von mexiko nie wer
jetzt anfängt zu studieren deswegen die
nächsten aufnahmen sind mit wald werfen
auf jeden fall bin ich jetzt sagen wir
damen und herren wir sehen uns im
nächsten block wieder in zwei tagen ihr
wisst bescheid freunde sein könnte game
locker lassen ab oder lassen ihr könnt
diesen uns auf jeden fall übermorgen
wieder freunde zu
[Musik]